Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here and today
I'm going to talk about pronunciation.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notification.
And for those of you who listen
on Apple Podcasts, please
feel free to leave a review.
We greatly appreciate it.
So pronunciation, the reason I want to
talk about pronunciation is actually
two things that happened today.
First of all, I had, we had
house guests, my wife and I.
These are very good friends,
we knew them from Japan, uh, he
was a consul general in Osaka.
Uh, he was a language student of Japanese
way back when I knew him in the early
seventies, he married a Japanese girl.
And so, you know, we've seen them from
time to time over the last 50 years.
They live in Kelowna.
They came by on their way to Whistler
and they overnighted with us and
we have, of course, we just talked
forever, went for walks and, uh, we were
talking about wine and he referred...
and he speaks French and he said,
uh, Sauvignon Blanc, Sauvignon.
You know, I've heard
people say Sauvignon Blanc.
He didn't, at least he didn't say Blanc.
And I thought to myself, he knows, I
mean, we have the sound in English.
It's not Sauvignon it's Sauvignon.
So we have the word, we have
that "o" sound in English.
Sauvignon, Sauvignon Blanc.
But because in English were a bit
sloppy in how we pronounce things.
Now, I'm sure, but I know he's a stickler.
Like I think even in speaking French,
he would say Sauvignon, it's Sauvignon.
So there's a certain lack
of attention to the sounds.
You hear this all the time.
And I think...
I'm going to give examples in other
languages where our English habits, if
we're English speakers, tend to dominate
our efforts to speak the foreign language.
Uh, now the other thing that was
brought to my attention, and this is
a, I think it was the person's name
was maybe Mike Murphy commenting here,
uh, on my, uh, one of my YouTube videos
about noticing that, uh, and he's been
teaching in China for a long time, and
the, even with all kinds of work with
the international phonetic alphabet
IPA, which I find quite unhelpful, but
people don't notice certain things.
And so he noticed though that a lot
of Chinese people can't pronounce
the word "usually" they say...
and absolutely I've heard so
many Chinese people say...
So I'm thinking about those two things.
So in English, we're a
bit lazy with our vowels.
So the vowelss, we don't say,
we don't clearly say Sauvignon.
Uh, and that's how English
is, you know, we just kind of
slur the vowels a little bit.
We don't give the vowels the full value,
but there are languages where they do like
French or Spanish or Japanese, full vowel.
In Russian and in Portuguese, some
of the vows kind of fall away,
but in, in many languages, they
want the full value for the vowel.
That's not to say that
they don't also slur.
So in French, you know, we want
to have a clear, you know...
but people then end up saying...so
that they don't give it full value.
And, you know, instead of saying...
they say...
So all of these things happen, but we
have to start by being able to notice
the clear, clean, correct pronunciation,
and we have to be able to do it.
And only once we have that correct
pronunciation, the ability to hear
it and to reproduce that clear proper
sound for that vowel in that language
only then can we afford to get sloppy.
So, and going back to the Chinese example,
of course, if you've ever been to Beijing
and taken a taxi, you can, I mean, even as
someone who speaks Chinese, it's hard to
follow them because it's...it's a very...
type of, if they're from Beijing.
Uh, and so maybe that's what carries
over into the English instead of
going "usually", you know, if you
really thought if that Chinese speaker
would, would sort of look at it.
And of course the problem in
English is that the words aren't
written the way they're pronounced.
So it's not...
there's not a soft...
sounded like in French, you know, where
you would have a J, which has a...
sound usually has that same sound,
but it's written S U "usually".
And of course, in most words, S U
doesn't have that, uh, you know, S value.
We say Supreme, Supreme,
suffer, uh, English is tough.
It ain't, it's just tough.
But I think that Chinese speakers and
there's so many of them who say...
they have to sit down and
look at that word and practice
saying that word correctly.
And then eventually they'll be able to
incorporate that word into a sentence that
they speak, you know, at normal speed.
And I remember that, you know, now I've
learned lots of languages, but French
and, uh, and Chinese were my first and I
actually worked hard at the pronunciation.
I remember the Chinese sound...
like
...
we don't have that in English.
So I had to work at it and I
would pronounce Chinese and
I particularly remember...
And to the point where the muscles here
in my, in my jaw were kind of sore.
Uh, I also remember trying very hard to
improve my French pronunciation because
even though we say like "pronunciation",
You really, if you're an English speaker,
you have to work hard to force yourself
to say "pronunciation", because the
tendency from English, which, which is
what our brain is set up for is to say
"pronunciation" it's not pronounced
"pronunciation" it's "pronunciation",
and it's, it takes an extra bit of
effort to give it that full value.
And once you have the full value, you
can then "pronunciation" you can kind
of slur over it a bit, but if you
don't have that essential, you know,
that core ability to make those sounds
correctly, then you're going to end
up with the equivalent of "usually"
that the Chinese use for usually.
And this is true in all languages.
I mean, Spanish also has pure vowels
and they're not dipthongs, so it's
not "bueno" an English speaker will
say "bueno", "no bueno" or whatever.
It's "bueno".
"bueno".
We have to focus in on that.
And I don't think the, uh,
international phonetic alphabet helps.
I think you have to listen very carefully
and then repeat very deliberately.
And, uh, you know, in a way, if you do
the mini stories at LingQ you get sentence
by sentence and you can hear the natural
uh, you know, voice read those sentences.
So you can, you can listen to
the sound, text to speech for
one word, but you can also hear a
sentence and then try to imitate it.
And when you try to imitate it,
really work the jaw muscles so that
you're giving it the full value.
If in the case of, uh, if
it's Chinese, then it's...
The real...
is coming in.
If it's French...if it's, uh, you
know, "bueno", "bueno" cut that "a",
it's not a "bueno" it's a "bueno".
And we have to hear those things.
We have to develop the ability to hear
the difference between how we sound
and how the native speaker sounds and
focus in on some of these key sounds.
So you build up a base, the ability to
make these sounds and it's difficult
at first, you might make it once, but
then within a sentence, you'll lose it.
I'll always remember in Montreal, I
used to hitchhike to McGill University
because you know, it was a long bus
ride and there was another fellow
hitchhiking and he was an immigrant
from Southern Italy and we got friendly.
In fact, we ended up looking for work
on construction sites in Montreal
together, and his English was
terrible and I was trying to help him.
And, uh, so he couldn't say small.
He would always say "small".
And it was frustrating, I said
saying no, no, no, no small.
Uh, okay.
So I would say go small.
And he went "small" for whatever reason
he was preprogrammed to say "small".
Maybe he heard it from other
people from Southern Italy.
I don't know.
In the end we worked construction
for a couple of months.
And then I went down to the dock
and I was able to hitchhike on a
boat going across to Europe so I
worked on a boat going across to
Europe and I haven't seen him since.
I don't know if he still says "small".
Sounds like the...
in French and in other languages
where they have an...sound,
that takes a lot of work.
And you know, that traditional
sort of suggestion is to go...
put your mouth in sort
of the shape to go...
and then just try and say E so if
you go...you'll end up with an...
even if you're able to produce
the...to get to the point where you can
produce it on the fly in a phrase or a
sentence, it takes a lot of practice.
Uh, so you got to notice it, you gotta
practice it individually and then you
want to get into doing it in sentences.
So my suggestion on pronunciation is
begin by really focusing, and so if you're
a Chinese speaker and you say you were
really get ahold of that word, look at it,
break it down, say u-su-a-lly, usually,
usually, usually usually get to where you
can say the word and then usually I like
to go, you know, and usually when I study
languages, I do this, that or the other.
So throw it into a sentence.
Now, second suggestion is to pronounce
well there's two things we have to
do: we got to hear it and we got
to be able to produce the sound.
We don't have to get a hundred
percent, but more or less.
The second thing is we don't
want to resist that sound.
You know, there are, we don't
want to resist anything that
has to do with that language.
So, you know, Swedish...and if
you uh feel self-conscious about
doing that, then you won't do it.
So you've got to not feel self-conscious.
And in that regard, I find that if you
can get a hold of, in that regard our
mini stories at LingQ are great because
they're kind of narrated without feeling.
I enjoyed when I was learning
Mandarin, I enjoyed the...
dialogues because there was a
lot of feeling in those, these
comedians telling a story.
And, uh, I think the same when we
learn languages, sometimes if we can
get ahold of something that's spoken
with feeling, that we connect at an
emotional level, and sometimes we can
have fun with it in different languages.
You know, we can say...
just sort of get into the...
you get into sort of almost like a
situation where emotion is involved and
so you, you play at the language and
so that way you're connecting, you're
creating some emotional connection.
The phrasiology and the pronunciation.
So I think all of those
things are important.
It begins by getting a grasp on how
it's actually pronounced, uh, you
know, making the effort to pronounce
correctly, which is more effort.
It's an effort to say"pronunciation"
"Sauvignon Blanc".
You gotta work at it until
eventually it becomes natural.
And then get a hold of something
that you can emotionally connect to.
And then imitate when people
speak with some emotion.
In most situations, you won't be,
you know, kind of wrapped up in that.
And, uh, but it, again, it helps.
And, and I think for people having
learned as many languages as I have,
and I have to admit that the first few
languages I worked hard on pronunciation.
And then I think that introduces a
level of flexibility in the brain.
So the subsequent languages, first of
all, there's a greater likelihood that
there will be sounds in there that we have
already noticed and been able to produce.
We're more confident, we're
less self-conscious and
so things become easier.
But the first few languages, I
think one has to make a special
effort to get, you know, a certain
minimum level of pronunciation.
It doesn't have to be perfect, but, um,
yeah, when I hear Sauvignon Blanc, if
the person is trying to speak French,,
to me that's just not good enough.
Anyway, there you have it.
Enjoy your Sauvignon Blanc.
Bye for now.